what's up guys welcome to my crib it's
Friday in addition to doing this regular
style we're going to do gamespot's top 5
news stories of the week in addition to
showing you my awesome digs
we'll start the tour in my trophy room
this is where we keep all the awards
that have fun all over the years this
place is still getting philsed you're
gonna see a few of the rough edges like
this fallout 3 statue that I'm having
built my honor right now you know
speaking of fallout there's a brand new
story that's coming out about new mod
looks like cel-shaded graphics check it
out the fallout 4 community is already
shown off what the RPG would look like
with higher resolution graphics but a
new fan made visual tweak goes in a
different direction redditor reddit is
wrong adjusted the game's visuals to
depict the game with a borderland style
cel-shaded graphics look this was made
possible by altering the sweet effects
rishe a DNB injector file and using a
combination of other mods you can
customize the ini file to your liking
how strong the border is stuff like that
developer Bethesda admitted that it
dialed back the game's graphics in part
to allow the studio to deliver a deep
level of interactivity so this mod
mucking up your alley if you prefer this
aesthetic our next stop we're gonna take
you on a tour through Giant Bomb who
have completely and utterly moved in
there absolutely a great example of how
it should be done around here anyway
back to the news scalebound and recore
have sadly both been delayed
record the upcoming adventure game from
Microsoft and mega man creator Keiji
Inafune a will not launch the spring as
originally planned a Microsoft
representative tells and gadget that the
xbox one and pc game is now slated to
arrive during the latter half of 2016
though an exact date was not divulged
scalebound the Xbox one exclusive action
RPG in development at Osaka studio
platinum games have been delayed to a
2017 release date and a message to fans
co-authored by several key developers at
platinum games studio claimed that the
extended deadline was necessary in order
to deliver on our ambitious vision next
up on our tour is the pit this is where
GameSpot producers works tirelessly to
provide you with the latest and greatest
in gaming news speaking of hot news this
week oculus released its price oculus VR
on Wednesday this week opened pre-orders
for the oculus rift consumer model which
means the preorder package which comes
with an Xbox one controller oculus
remote sensor and free copies of a
Valkyrie and Lucky's tale as well as the
cables you need to get started is going
to cost you a 600 bucks the headset
start shipping on March 28 there's a
limit of one per customer the
recommendation memory requirement is 8
gigabytes of RAM while the processor
recommendation is a mid-range Intel i5
4590 the graphics card shouldn't be less
powerful than the NVIDIA GTX 970 or the
AMD r9 290 meanwhile four USB ports are
required for all parts of the peripheral
to work oculus recommends that three of
these are USB 3.1 sag aim spot tour
without a look into the fridge
in our fourth news story sounds like we
will not be getting a new assassin's
creed game for the entire year since the
release of assassins creed two in 2009
we've gotten a new entry in the core
franchise every year alongside spin-offs
in the case of the most recent years
that won't be the case this year though
as a new report suggests that Ubisoft
will skip 2016 in favor of a 2017
release for a new game set in Egypt the
game is currently called Assassin's
Creed Empire and could signal a biannual
release schedule for the series going
forward it also says the hole in you
Vsauce fall schedule could be filled by
watchdogs to which is reportedly set in
downtown sweet sweet San Francisco
finally we conclude our tour with a
brief look at the lobby we're currently
Danny and Andy are working their butts
off to make a brand new live show tomb
raiders coming out on pcs in January
rise of the Tomb Raider will launch for
PC on january 28 square enix and Crystal
Dynamics announced the action-adventure
game debuted in November 2015 as a timed
exclusive for xbox one and 360 s the pc
edition of rides the tomb raider was
developed by Crystal Dynamics and Nick's
s software it'll support 4k resolution
to offer stunning new detail hot rize
the tomb raider will be available
through physical retailers and online
marketplaces such as steam window store
and square enix's own store Standard
Edition is 60 bucks while digital deluxe
edition which features the game and it's
DLC path is 90 rise the tomb raider is
also coming to ps4 but not until holiday
2016
so that's it for our tour of GameSpot
and our top five news stories of the
week that's it for me I gotta go back to
work get out of here